joining me now with reaction Rudy
Giuliani attorney for president Trump
mayor thank you so much for being here
know if you'd be here yeah you just
heard me say that great open there thank
you there must be repercussions the bad
actors whether it's Chicago or in this
case a lot of victims in this Trump
Russia collusion hoax I think the
president puts it best when he says just
can't happen again and the only way you
can assure this will not happen to
another president is to find out what
happened and who's responsible for it
the I think it's got to be clear to any
fair-minded person that whole idea of
conspiracy with the Russians to
interfering the election collusion if
you want to call it that it's totally
untrue three investigations not a single
bit of evidence every single witness who
CNN said was a blockbuster witness
totally fell apart Jeff Zucker today I'm
gonna get to this in the next well he
said there's no regrets he says we have
nothing to apologize maybe we don't have
a color not investigators they're
journalists maybe they don't have a
conscience I mean they hyped every how
many blockbusters was that Papadopoulos
man afford one after the other at Cohen
Cohen any totally fell apart the guy's
got to be prosecuted for perjury so who
did it this started somewhere didn't
come out of thin air somebody came up
with the idea that they were gonna get
manna for it they were gonna get Trump
and perpetrated this hoax and then a lot
of people committed a lot of crimes in
order to work it out just if you just
focus on the four affidavits clear
perjury Comey
Comey has to be brain dead to have
thought that the that distill dossier
was a legitimate intelligence document
it is a joke call me actually spoke out
tonight by the way oh we have came out
of the trees yeah he's out of the red do
you make it out of the challenge I
couldn't tell the redwood from Comey
all right so here's what confused these
are these are keepers looking for the
emails new comments the part that's
confusing is I can't quite understand
what's going on with the obstruction
stuff and I have great faith in Bob
mother but I just can't tell from the
letter why he didn't decide the
questions when the entire rationale for
this special counsel is to make sure
that the politicals
aren't making the key charging decision
he saw he's hitting this old pal boiler
there
he's not political apparently is another
one so he's hitting always hitting bar
obviously yeah I take a look to take a
look at the affidavit right
the affidavit puts forth the still
dossier as a real legitimate
intelligence document well first of all
they don't disclose he with holes which
i think is perjury really
certainly misleading the court fraught
on the court he withholds the fact that
1.1 million dollars was paid by the
opponent of Donald Trump so it's not an
intelligence document it's a 1.1 million
dollar campaign document second the
thing has in it totally absurd things
like Trump was an agent of the Russian
government for 10 years and they decided
five years ago from that date that he
was gonna be President but he's around
in the Redwoods he stays touring the
country on his book tour I'll give you
another one why maybe he's the laziest
guy in America but the still dossier
says did Michael Cohen was in Prague on
a specific date how difficult is it to
call up the stadium or now they don't
want to check it well why not check it
supposed to do that so we're talking
about I think the word he made up was
fun gross negligence yes yeah maybe he's
guilty of it not just Hillary this guy's
got to be investigators and he's got to
be do you think deeper to that I hope so
I hope he doesn't get off because he
likes to look at Redwood sir I mean he
perpetrated a fraud on the court and
he's either grossly grossly negligent or
he was acting deliberately mayor we
spoke about some denialism at the other
networks and this was Don Lemon and
Chris Cuomo's reaction to your interview
on CNN last night let's watch Oh Chris
Giuliani I've known most of my life okay
we've had plenty of nasty back-and-forth
we try to disagree with decency he
demanded an apology from me tonight for
asking 10 questions me and I meant what
I said there ain't no damn apology
coming they're taking a victory lap for
not being felons that's how low the
standard is for behavior right now
that's pathetic
felons first of all on collusion he was
completely exonerated it really said
that
president said the report couldn't have
been better is that do you agree with
that the report could look I probably
did a hundred of those declination
letters I've never seen one stronger and
with that slight little but I can't
exonerate him back I can't charge him
but I can't exactly that was a weak
sister mom not only weak I was afraid
and totally unethical you're not
supposed to say that in a declination
letter you're not supposed well I'm just
I think white I think there are two
sides of Muller there's the good guys
side in the Wiesmann side and I think
why some want a few of the battles and I
do think it's pathetic that mullet
couldn't make us much I actually do he
couldn't get where you couldn't get you
guys to bring the president and to sit
down for questions because why would you
why would you did you ever get close to
sitting down with the president sitting
down with the mother team let them think
we were because you guys strung them out
for a long time which I thought was
brilliant but I but I was absolutely
convinced that they're a bunch of I mean
half of them are good guys good women
half of them are totally unethical
prosecutors the kind of prosecutors that
I would have fired in two minutes when I
was the US Attorney Weisman should never
go near a courtroom in his entire I
haven't seen him the man is a the man is
horrible by the way they go whether
they're going after bill bar now former
HW George HW Attorney General what now
Attorney General for the president who
before he talked about Trump everyone
loved Bob bill bar but now let's watch
there were two major criticisms of what
bill Barr did one that he inserted
himself into the process when he didn't
need to and to that he did it hastily
they hand the the fragile pure baby to a
political appointee and there turns out
and all with very aggressive views and
what we saw last week is why a lot of
people notice I didn't want to trust him
because they were afraid he'd do
something like this well first I wasn't
political about bill bar he wasn't at
the Trump victory party like Weissman
was crying at Hillary's Christmas party
he didn't run the the Trump foundation
like gee Neary who worked for Muller ran
the Clinton Foundation that's where the
political partisans were bill Barr is a
professional professional law
enforcement guy professional lawyer he
happens to be Attorney General the way
Michael Mukasey was Attorney General not
the political operatives like like
Clinton
like like Obama had so I don't get it
but in any event that decision was also
made by Rosenstein rosin seed started
this investigation you think he's going
to sell out on an obstruction the theory
of obstruction you have to give in your
law degree if you're bought into
obstruction when the whole investigation
took place what did he obstruct you
don't need you don't need an underlying
crime but it is an important element as
he pointed out you don't need it it's
not critical very difficult to prove
intent when there's no underlying crime
why would it take weeks to get this full
report instead of because there's a
there's a whole pit full of 60 material
6 a meaning meaning the grand jury
material which is a felony if you make a
mistake and if you think if Barr made a
mistake what do you think Schumer and
Pelosi and Adam Schiff shifts no shift
yeah Adam Schiff would do right they'd
be yelling and screaming he should be
prosecuted so he's got to be very
careful maybe he's going to go to a
judge to get it released maybe they're
gonna try to exercise it from the front
from it I would like the whole thing out
Laura I am absolutely convinced we can
answer no if you read this this letter
there's no smoking gun you can't come to
the conclusion that's absolutely never
said well there's a lot of obstruction
like behavioural that is that is written
about it's not a single fact you don't
know about there you haven't seen it so
how do you know it's I know I know
what's in it God Almighty you don't
think after all these months we don't
have a pretty good idea of what's in
there having debated it with them taught
you that preparing for like let's say
the bizarre happens and House of
Representatives has a death wish a
political death wish and goes to a
vitamin Road are you are you all ready
for that now absolutely we have a we
have a very very long multifaceted memo
written already that we can cut and
paste depending on what they I mean the
collusion part of it probably isn't
necessary now so we can take that all
out so if they want to battle over
obstruction they can make fools out of
themselves how about you bring a case
against Trump on obstruction he didn't
delete 30,000 emails
he didn't bust up a server
he didn't have a hammer didn't take a
hammer to that you can infer intent
right Lydia Trudy I remember that lost
good when you're smashing this stuff you
and further you know you know you know
you know what they want to do their
whole theory and we had this debate with
them often they want to look in his
brain and say although he didn't do
anything to obstruct the investigation
he thought my thinking about it during
one discussion with them I said you know
we haven't we don't have a brain x-ray
machine that gets your thoughts and if
we started prosecuting people for
thoughts half of America would be in
jail we wouldn't have this town would be
emptied out front you should drive
around no traffic Rudi
please all right some of your friends in
the media said a few things about you a
few weeks ago and they love you but now
it's kind of come up in it's time let's
watch who did Rudy Giuliani harm the
president yeah I think I think it hurt
the president and the White House is
Rudy Giuliani helping or hurting the
president helping or hurting well yes or
no I don't know I it seems to be hurting
unless there's some deep strategy I
don't understand here so that was on
who's cooler depends on who's colluding
or like maybe they're just not smart
enough to have figured out this dry feel
sorry for them of course there was a
strategy to it and of course what I came
to the conclusion when I came into this
case a year ago we had a defendant on
two levels
we had a defendant legally with them
argue the law argue the facts try to
delay them as long as possible so he
could build as good a case in case they
did give us a subpoena that they don't
they don't get a subpoena they're not
entitled to it but on the second hand I
realized immediately we don't have a
jury here we're not gonna try this to a
jury we're gonna try this to a possible
impeachment so who is that it's the
American public we had to change public
appeal
but public opinion still says I mean
this is a new poll that came out today
that half of the nearly half of the
country thinks that Trump obstructed
justice which is a messaging problem for
the White House I don't know why the
number would be that way not with what
happened okay because Molly that's that
little little line that Muller left I
don't know what that is but I saw one
five day I'm gonna let a cop hole I saw
a pole you don't care about fifty
percent fifty percent thought it was a
witch-hunt look
long as those poles are within striking
distance they're not gonna not gonna
feature and today even on CNN there were
two political experts Democrats on
saying pitch was out of the question now
and Pelosi gave you the standard which
is you got to get bipartisan support
there's no Republican that's gonna
support impeachment given what would you
do to celebrate did you do anything this
way often special we had nice dinner and
the president had us over to the White
House on Sunday night and he had us for
lunch on Monday and he let us fool
around with the with the Washington
Capitals much bigger rings I saw I
finally got the collusion with the
Vatican there I saw that the closer I
grabbed Ovechkin and I said I'm gonna
destroy that picture like Sonny Corleone
I'm gonna take that camera I'm gonna
break it and throw cash look at you I
said I'm gonna I must break you
he is so big and so strong great to see
you as always thanks for coming in